Cómo interpretar las declaraciones de
bolsonaro qué mensaje envía el hecho de
que no haya reconocido abiertamente su
derrota pero sí autoriza una transición
De poder sí Hola Claro lo reconoció la
derrota para para Lula públicamente
porque eso sería como que desmovilizar
sus apoyadores incluso es importante
recordar que muchos de Ellos están en
las carreteras bloqueando las carreteras
de Brasil desde el sur hasta el norte
del país en este momento ya hace más o
menos 24 horas que están volteando
varias partes del país sin embargo Acabo
de recibir la noticia de que
evolucionaron reconoció si la derrota a
puertas cerradas en una reunión con los
ministros de la suprema corte pero antes
como tú mencionabas
el el jefe de gabinete de bolsonaro
empezó
la transición y Lula por su parte
también creó un gabinete pequeño pero
gabinete de transición para que los dos
gobiernos lo que sale en lo que se
encuentra empiecen a hablar sobre sobre
los términos y los detalles de la
transición ahora refiriéndose a los
bloqueos de los que estamos hablando de
Los camioneros dijo que son el resultado
de indignación y sentimiento de
injusticia por como se dio el proceso
electoral está sembrando dudas tal vez
sobre los comicios como se temía
Sí este es el argumento que Los
camioneros están ahí por por indignación
por injusticia por el sentimiento
personal de cada uno de Los camioneros
por injusticia Pero hay una desconfianza
de que este es un movimiento profesional
muchísimo más coordinado del que de que
la respuesta de ciudadanos que que
estaría indignados con con los
resultados los conteos del último
domingo entonces hay que mantener
atención a este movimiento sin embargo
gobernadores de estados que eran
apoyadores se siguen siendo como que
aliados de bolsonaron Ya empezaron a
mandar sus policías como podemos ver en
las imágenes mandar sus policías para
desmovilizar este bloqueos incluso
porque ya empieza la presión de
empresarios de distintos sectores que
tienen sus intereses económicos y este
es bloqueos son malísimos o muy malos
para para los negocios para el comercio
para para los transportes en fin para
para el consumo de los supermercados de
las ciudades de todo más claro ya las
autoridades habrían advertido sobre el
uso de la fuerza bolsonaro también
resaltó la representación que tiene la
derecha en el congreso es Tal vez un
mensaje a luna recordándole que no le
será fácil gobernar Claro claro que sí
tiene su partido y sus partidarios
tienen mayoría tanto en la cámara de
diputados como en el senado de la
República de Brasil entonces luna va a
tener que pero ya tiene claro es un
político extremamente expediente muy
hábil Pero va a tener que tener mucha un
trabajo muy
profundo de articulación con distintos
sectores que que no los apoyan en este
momento Entonces va a tener que negociar
muchísimo pero va a tener también la
ayuda de su vicepresidente que es el
gobernador de ex gobernador de San Pablo
gerado algin que también es un
articulador muy hábil y un político
bastante expediente Creo yo que Lula y
el Congreso Nacional van a llegar a buen
término a buen término a partir de enero